brought to you by Far Cry primal rise
above extinction in stores February 23rd
lah Cry primal feels very similar to its
predecessors even though it's got a
brand new wildly different setting now
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing is entirely up to you but in this
sponsored episode I wanted to tell you
about some of the cool things I found
with the game when I got a chance to
play it a few weeks ago
possibly the most enticing thing about
Far Cry primal is the riddles of
wildlife that you can befriend and if
there are people bearing size even right
it is great fun going off to train with
the mildly insane beast Master will let
you tame the local wildlife you craft
yourself some bait and then drop back
into some nearby flora while your wolf
cougar or bear soon to be best friend
goes for the goods you then approach
them slowly and tame them with your
sweet animal power
they will then follow you around attack
your enemies and let you pet them there
are a whole lot of different animals
that can be tamed so you can either
catch them all or just rely on your
favorite like ash and pikachu or in my
case
Articuno objectively the best pokemon as
i mentioned you can also ride on and
attack with some of the larger beasties
in lieu of running people over with a
jeep which is pretty epic Far Cry has
always been keen on letting you create
chaos with fire but primal is upping the
ante by letting you set any of your
weapons alight so that fiery chaos is
always right around the corner just like
in the good old days that is caveman
times fire is the bill and end-all Far
Cry primal is no different you can set
all your weapons and subsequently
enemies on fire get instant flaming
projectiles by setting your arrowheads
alight and set one of your clubs our
likes to create burning torches which
you can use to ward off the things that
go bump in the night once the Sun Goes
Down
Far Cry primal is a lot more threatening
in the night so you'll want to hang on
to your stores of animal fat so you can
create fire on the fly while you'll
certainly have a ball using fire to your
advantage it's worth remembering that
there is a whole tribe dedicated to how
much they love burning everybody up so
watch yourself if you felt like the Far
Cry games have been seriously lacking
and giving you opportunities to fly and
transfer your soul into the body of an
owl and primal will be the game for you
Far Cry primal lets you sync up with an
owl who appears to be a kind of spirit
guide you fly through a series of
picturesque ethereal nature scenes
before bonding with it and from that
point you'll be able to use him to scout
ahead
tag enemies and even
scratch the eyes out of people you don't
like you can also spend skill points
improving your hour pal which will
expand its abilities to things like
dropping [ __ ] on people you're our pal
is particularly handy given that driving
quickly to new locations and scouting
far ahead with a sniper rifle is no
longer an option
crafting is really big right now and
games like Faro tend to ask you to do a
lot of hunting and collecting plants and
crap now we don't really have any
problem with that but there is something
special about doing hunting and
gathering in the actual era of hunting
and gathering while being stranded on a
hostile Island is part of the course in
this series it's really interesting to
feel like the things you're picking up
and crafting have a very real and
genuine history of being used by our
ancestors although it is massively
simplified in-game there's even
something to learn about how to make
fire healing salves and okay so maybe
combining animal fat with pottery won't
actually give you grenades in the worlds
of things that actually exist not to
mention that's about 11,000 years too
early to be historically accurate but
for the most part the crafting and
hunting feels contextually necessary and
sensible here's a secret that isn't
really a secret if you've ever seen me
play a game I suck at aiming especially
when what I'm aiming at is speedy
caveman cannibal targets all up in my
face
I will take a club over a bow and arrow
any day and thankfully primal is very
happy to let me do that since there was
a significant lack of high-powered
firearms and flame throwers in 10,000 BC
you'll be getting in there with your
assorted sticks and stones a lot while
you can throw all your weapons in primal
either strategically or by accidentally
hitting the wrong button like I did you
will mostly be getting up close and
personal since plenty of your enemies
favor the wake from that as a result
close quarters combat and takedowns are
way more satisfying you'll still want to
avoid getting surrounded but it's great
fun to smash accountable space to bits
with a club you know before you
inevitably break your club onset face
let me know down in that comment section
if you're going to be playing Far Cry
primal and what you're particularly keen
for especially if it's something I
didn't mention
this sponsored episode I will see you
again with a new episode in two weeks